hello and welcome to the take with
Sophie Ridge live at nine o'clock from
the hearts of Westminster
24 rapes over two decades committed by a
serving police officer after the
conviction of David Carrick and the
Revelation that a further 800 officers
are being investigated for sexual and
domestic abuse claims We'll be asking
how can women trust the police and is
there anything more the government
should be doing as we get takes from all
sides over the next 60 minutes
when it comes to the honorable gentleman
he isn't just for the free movement of
people he's also got the free movement
of principles
there was a usual ding dong between
where she's sunac and kirstama at pmqs
plus this
Mr Speaker let me be crystal clear this
is the conservative party she came to
stalk a culture war against some of the
most marginalized people in society
we'll hear more from him Stephen Flynn
the S P's leader in Westminster and that
constitutional Rao but first we are
going to be talking to the home office
Minister Robert jamrick and will also be
joined by the shadow Home Secretary
Yvette keeper that is all coming up on
the take
foreign
[Music]
good evening strikes the NHS misogyny in
the police and the Constitutional row
over gender recognition it's been a
sobering political start to 2023 even if
you're not doing during January we'll be
discussing some of those issues in the
next hour but let's start with the best
bits of the week so far
the Metropolitan Police has today
apologized to the victims of a serving
officer who has admitted more than 70
serious sexual offenses including 24
counts of rape the police must address
the failings in this case restore public
confidence and ensure the safety of
women and girls I'm sorry I'm sorry that
we've let you down and you have my
absolute word we're going to be ruthless
about sorting this out let's get more
now on the UK government's decision to
block changes to gender recognition laws
in Scotland which Nicholas sturgeon has
called a full frontal attack on the
Scottish Parliament I have not taken
this decision lightly the government has
looked closely at the potential impact
of the bill and I've considered all
relevant policy and operational
implications together with the minister
for women inequalities veteran this
legislation is an unprecedented attack
on the Scottish Parliament tens of
thousands of nurses are on strike as the
deadlock over NHS pay looks set to
deepen this afternoon we're at the head
of the march here there are
several hundred NHS workers here there
are nurses there are doctors there are
other NHS workers in in solidarity GMB
ambulance workers are determined and
resolute they're not going to back down
for one week will he stop blaming others
take some responsibility and just admit
under his watch the NHS is in crisis
isn't it this is about the fact that the
NHS in Scotland in Wales in England is
dealing with unprecedented challenges
recovering from kovid dealing with a
very virulent and early flu season and
everyone is doing their best to bring
those wait times down
or whether it's the NHS or the police it
really does feel like our public
services are under pressure and under
scrutiny as well uh let's go first shall
we to my interview that we did with
Robert generick the home office Minister
particularly of course in the wake of
that conviction of a serving police
officer David Carrick
we of course have heard the horrific
story of a serving police officer
convicted of 80 sex attacks as a serving
officer what are you doing to restore
faith in the Met well you're right to
say this was one of the most egregious
cases I think we've ever seen in the
history of the met and perhaps even in
modern policing and so we have to take
very robust action not least because
it's not an isolated incident it's part
of a pattern of behavior which is
seriously eroded trust in in policing so
we're doing a number of things firstly
we are conducting a review
urgently on the vetting and recruitment
procedures in policing and we've asked a
very experienced former judge to do that
piece of work for us and that's going to
look at how people get into the service
what checks are put in place when
they're promoted and how generally this
culture of misogyny and Prejudice has
arisen within the force do you think
there is a culture of misogyny then well
the evidence suggests that doesn't it
certainly in in the Met police and uh
Dame Louise Casey who's conducted an
interim piece of work for the Met came
to broadly those conclusions the second
thing that we've announced today is that
where officers fall seriously below the
standard that is expected of them
whether it's misconduct or serious poor
performance there needs to be ways in
which they can be disciplined and
dismissed from the surface in a faster
fashion than happens today and so again
we have invested we've set up a short
investigation as to how that can happen
and then the third thing that we're
doing is working with constabers right
across the country to put in place
better vetting procedures now and we've
provided them with the funding to do
that so as we're uplifting the numbers
officers quite significantly across the
country we should be making sure that
any of those individuals men and women
who come into the service are properly
vetted at that point
you know the thing that I've been sort
of wrestling with today you know if
you're a rape victim you know that less
than one percent of recorded rapes
result in a conviction you know you hear
the stories of people like David Carrick
who carried out all these attacks who
had a nickname amongst his colleagues
that I can't repeat on TV because
frankly they knew he was a robin you'll
be thinking how can I trust the Met why
should I report a crime to them well I
think that trust in the police has been
seriously eroded by this case and by
some of the other very prominent and
serious cases in recent times that's why
these reviews are important we set these
in train actually before these events
came to light and that's why a lot rests
now on uh Sir Mark Riley who came in
really precisely to do this job to turn
around the met in particular to address
some of these serious concerns and the
Home Secretary and I have spoken with
him and have been clear that he now
needs to investigate these cases and if
there are individuals who turned a blind
eye to this they should be disciplined
or fired from the service and he should
be putting in place the procedures to
make sure this doesn't happen again I do
have confidence in him he is a very
strong police officer with a great
history and track record of service and
he's got a big job ahead of him which
he's recognized himself he's been very
clear about the challenge and he knows
the needs to get on and deliver that
talking about people who turn to Blind
Eye which you think his predecessors did
enough
well a culture a culture has arisen over
a long period of time which now needs to
be changed and if there are predecessors
of him well then that's a question for
them but if there are serving officers
who are still in the metropolitan police
or need another constabularys then uh
they need to be removed or that they
need to change their ways um just to
move on to other issues now and when
Russia sunak you know first stood on the
steps of Downing Street as prime
minister he said that his mandate was a
2019 election and he promised to deliver
on leveling up how's that going
well we've never said that leveling up
was the job of a single year or even a
single Parliament it's which is lucky
because yeah well I disagree with that
actually I think it's a generational
task to change long-standing economic
and social inequalities in this country
which can be traced back to the second
world war or or even earlier than that
we have made I think some very good
progress we're now investing billions of
pounds in towns and smaller cities
across this country that have been
neglected for too long initiatives like
the townsfund for example like the
leveling up fund which is announcing
further grants this week uh putting tens
of millions of pounds into places like
where I represent in Nottinghamshire and
the East Midlands that have not seen
government attention for a very long
time and we're passing through
Parliament as we speak a landmark piece
of legislation the leveling up Bill
which sets lasting goals for this
government and those that follow where
we should be able to track as a country
how we are doing to take forward social
Mobility poor educational performance
Health inequalities lack of investment
in communities and local government and
it is a mission that we're as committed
to today as I think we were when we were
elected in 2019. you talked about health
inequalities and of course another big
part of that 2019 Manifesto was the
Pledge to build 40 new hospitals how
many have been built
uh well some have been built and opened
that you may have seen the Duke of Duke
and Duchess of Cambridge the Princeton
Princess of Wales uh opening one in
Liverpool just the other day that was a
part of that program that we're still
committed to the program we're working
through this now uh preparing the plans
some of these are Big projects that will
take some time uh but I think the health
secretary has been very clear that we're
going to deliver on this so you are
going to deliver just because my
understanding is two have been completed
work started on a further seven I mean
that leaves what 31 to go it's not going
to happen is it you need to build 40 by
2030. uh well I hope it is and we remain
committed to it as I say something is a
very large project in fact there's one
in uh in Nottinghamshire where I
represent which is a huge project taking
a major hospital and planning for its
complete rebuild these things don't
happen quickly but the commitment is
there because one of the things you see
with the NHS is that for all of the
Rising uh Revenue spend that's been put
into it in recent years one of the
things that it's not had is capital
spend on new hospitals and facilities
and so it is a critical program we will
deliver on it okay we will deliver on it
we'll have to wait and see by 2030.
um I want to also ask that reports in
the sun on Sunday about Nadeem zahari
the party chairman that he's made a
seven-figure settlement with hmrc over
tax and the Prime Minister spokesman
said that the PM takes Nadeem zahawi at
his word do you I do I've not seen any
evidence to suggest that there's any
impropriety I don't think you have
either there was an article in the in
the Sun newspaper that made some
suggestions and he was very clear in his
rebuttal he said that he had always paid
his taxes and his taxes are up to date
and that seems a pretty clear statement
as far as I can tell as a minister when
you come into office you make a
commitment that your taxes are in order
uh I I believe Nadeem zahawi uh has made
in that statement that that it was in
the Sun newspaper pretty clear statement
that he pays his taxes in the UK as he
should do I I guess my point is that I'm
not that clear I suppose you know we
don't know how much he settled with for
hmrc we don't know why he did what it
was for is it really clear
it hasn't been that clear well I don't
think there are I have I mean you may
follow the story more closely than I
have I'm not an expert on his tax
Affairs but I've not seen any evidence
of impropriety or inappropriate behavior
I'm just asking that and so
in the absence of any evidence of uh of
impropriety I'm not sure what what the
questions are to be answered if if there
are concerns or has he then raised them
and then raise them for with him that's
why as no one has uh brought forward any
any serious evidence I it's not clear to
me that there is a case to be answered
for here but you know obviously Nadeem
zahari has to answer those questions
himself uh if there are genuine
questions to be answered okay uh I just
finally I can't resist this question uh
the foods and Thunder's agency
chairwoman has said that we shouldn't
have cake in the office she's compared
being around cake in the office as
passive smoking
killjoy yes I mean I did see a snippet
of that but sounds uh you know a bit
unrealistic I think we've all brought in
cakes on our birthdays and I'm not a big
home Baker but there are plenty of good
people in my private office at home
office uh who who do bring in things so
that sounds ridiculous to me of course
obesity is important but you've got to
do it in sensible ways have you ever um
an ambushed by cake in the office uh
well it was my birthday actually last
week and so my private office did bring
in a so in that sense yes but it was a
it was a very welcome Ambush okay thank
you very much thank you indeed Robert
Jam right there
I couldn't resist the Ambush line uh
they're in the midst of a very serious
interview about the government's
response to misogyny and crime in the
Met police so we heard from Robert
jemery let's find out Labor's response
uh shall we I've been talking to the
shadow Home Secretary Yvette Cooper
I just want to first get your reaction
to uh David Carrick the serving police
officer convicted of 80 sex attacks is
there a misogyny problem in the police I
think this is deeply serious this is the
most awful awful case because it's a
serial rapist that's one of the worst
serial rape cases that we have had in
Britain and to be a serving police
officer for so long he should never have
been in the police should never have
been allowed to serve for so long and
the police clearly missed series of
opportunities to take action so I think
this is extremely serious and for it to
also come at the same time as Wayne
cousins was being prosecuted when the
met and police forces across the country
knew that they had an issue about not
taking action when these sorts of
serious concerns are raised and yet they
still failed to act in this case too so
I think major changes needed and that
means a proper overhaul on on misconduct
on vetting on standards but I am really
really worried that we're getting still
nothing serious from the home office or
from the government they've got to take
action not simply have the warm words
and leave it to policing I interviewed
uh Robert generic just before you and he
was making a big play of what the
government is doing he says look they're
strengthening the vetting procedures
there's going to be more checks for
existing officers to make sure that
there's no one who is currently serving
who shouldn't be and also making easy to
dismiss officers to their concerns do
you welcome that but so far they're not
actually doing any of these things so
we've been calling on them for a long
time to have proper mandatory
requirements on vetting they're still
not doing that I mean I'm just what does
it means a requirement for every police
force to meet certain basic minimum
standards on vetting so at the moment it
is okay for a police forces to not even
do character references to not do proper
interviews before they are taking on
somebody in the police so not to do some
of these basic vetting checks it's a
matter for police forces there's
guidance but guidance isn't good enough
there have to be proper requirements
things have to be compulsory so we've
been calling on the government for a
long time to make some of these vetting
Arrangements compulsory to have proper
systems in place to have some compulsory
training and standards in place to
hugely strengthen the misconduct rules
and systems so still for example the
police can just look at an in individual
case rather than looking at the whole
pattern of someone's behavior and as a
result we've seen cases where no action
is taken where there are some very
serious problems so a whole series of
areas where we have been calling for
some time for Mandatory Action from the
home office and instead what you get is
the home office just says well the
police need to take action in this area
and then they get distracted and they
walk away and there's no follow-up
nothing to make sure it happens and as a
result women are being let down and
policing is being let down because this
undermines confidence in some of the
excellent work that there are police
officers doing every single day but of
course confidence in that is being
undermined yeah it's important isn't it
when you say confidence is being
undermined because what does that mean
that means you know victims but
particularly I guess female victims of
sexual assault of rape
looking at these stories and thinking
why should I report yeah exactly and
that's why labor would change the law in
this area so that we've got those
mandatory standards on vettings so that
we have much stronger requirements
around misconduct training those sorts
of checks in place but it does it's part
of a wider issue around making sure that
there is action on violence against
women and girls again I've spoken to to
police officers who are you know busting
a gut to tackle predatory men to tackle
problems about serious crimes against
women and girls but we still know again
the system isn't strong enough of the
300 women who are likely to have been
raped across the country today barely a
handful of those cases will ever reach
court and that is just devastating
that's terrible ministers promised over
nearly a year ago that they would make
actional violence against women and
girls part of the Strategic policing
requirement that's part of the
obligations on all police forces it's
not
you've actively got people feeling that
nothing's going to be done it's not
going to be properly investigated no
one's going to get back to me it's never
going to make it to court and so as a
result you have victims who
understandably have been through one of
the most devastating crimes of all who
are withdrawing now I know that there
are officers who are so committed to
turning that round and to getting
Justice for those women but it isn't
happening and there has to be proper
home office action and I just think the
conservatives haven't taken this
seriously enough they haven't taken the
action that we need a couple of other
things and I was Keen to ask you about
and there are reports that Nadeem zahawi
has made a seven figure settlement with
hmrc the Prime Minister says he's
addressed it Robert generic says that
he's been very clear
um should that be the end of the matter
I think there needs to be just a proper
cabinet inquiry into this to make sure
that everything has happened
that's what um I think the labor house
party has called for just to make sure
that things have happened properly
because obviously you know there are
reports that concerns were raised and he
became Chancellor for a period in the
chaotic year that we have had that he
was for a Time the chancellor of the
exchequer you have to make sure that
we're cabinet ministers are obviously
you know following all of the rules that
there has to be proper reassurance
finally
um you're one of the few members of The
Shadow cabinet who's been in the actual
cabinet uh before as a minister uh under
the last Labor government do you think
going to be back in there I hope so
that's what we're obviously working hard
for you'll have heard again say no
complacency we are working very hard all
of the time
but you just have to say you know if you
look at the total chaos and the total
shambles that this government is I just
strongly believe in the changes that a
labor government can make to get our
economy growing get our Public Services
sorted out and to just end this chaos uh
okay don't attempt there obviously bet
Cooper thank you very much for being on
the program today
at burial message there it's all labor
politicians are if I start to talk a
little bit about the possibility of them
being in Government after the next
election now a little later we are going
to be hearing from the SMP but first
let's get the take on what we've heard
so far with our Deputy political answer
Sam coats uh Sam how are you doing what
are your main takeaways from the program
nice to be back
um I was struck by that interview with
Robert generick it's effective number
two in the home office now big picture
which is an awful lot of generalities
whether it was leveling up being a
generational thing or uh some of the new
hospitals he hoped to deliver or the
issues around the police well we're
still in the inquiry stage we are 12
years into conservatives being in
Downing Street and what I wasn't getting
any sense of is was language of delivery
what what have they done what can they
do between now and the next election
then and that's to that quite a lot for
me but but for me Sophie the bit of the
interview is a bit at the end where you
were asking him about content deposit
chairman Nadim zahawi and his tax
Affairs and what Robert genrex seemed to
suggest was that in the absence of you
waving around some tax return or
producing hard evidence Nadine Tahari
has no case to answer or no questions to
answer when it comes to his tax Affairs
but you were asking him a very specific
question about a story in the sun on
Sunday this week I'm going to read you
the first two sentences that story said
Nadim zahawi has agreed to pay several
million in tax after scrutiny of his
family's financial affairs sources said
his Representatives will some stump up a
seven-figure stum to settle a dispute
with hmrc now Mr zahari spokesman simply
says last summer that his taxes were
fully paid and he was not aware of any
investigation now that doesn't feel like
a denial of the two main points the sun
was making nothing that Robert generick
said amounted to a denial of the key
claim so I think viewers are gonna just
start to make up their own mind it does
feel doesn't it and that the questions
are coming even if of course
um there's no suggestion of impropriety
is as Mr generic says and the the
Statesman the spokespa people quotes are
there obviously as well
um anything else that you're looking out
for in particular this week sir so I
think this week
we are we're in a bit of a kind of
Groundhog Day with um with politics
um so much of this year has been either
about the NHS or about strikes or those
two issues have really have really
really come together tomorrow we've got
a gear change I think the Prime Minister
wants to talk about leveling up there's
going to be money sprinkled all around
key constituencies but I've been over in
the Commons this evening talking to Tory
MPS and they're the question for them
and they've had a sneak peek about
what's coming tomorrow is where the
money is uh being distributed one said
that what you're going to find is that
it's going to labor Heartland Labor
marginals and Tory uh uh sort of safe
seats and they were just why on Earth
are they not fighting in the marginals
well I just don't quite understand the
politics behind Richie sunax decisions
now we only have that MP's word for it
we'll have to see tomorrow but it's
essentially another toy MP questioning
uh Rishi sunax political judgment one
more time so we'll find out tomorrow how
true that is it's quite interesting
isn't it the political judgment is
something that comes across a lot uh
people in this party sort of questioning
is he a bit Eve politically he's only
been in Westminster for a few years
compared to some of the Decades that
others have been here and not to mention
other two
Sam are always good to talk we'll hear
more out from Sam later on the program
plus his Westminster accounts project as
well you're watching the take live in
Westminster coming up is the round
between Hollywood and Westminster all
about the gender recognition all the
push for Scottish independence we'll be
hearing from the s p leader in the UK
Parliament Stephen Flynn
thank you
[Music]
hello welcome back uh we are live in
Westminster you're watching the take now
there's been an awful lot of debate uh
this week about Scotland's the Scottish
government's decision to make it easier
and quicker for people to legally change
their gender of course this has now
blown up into a big constitutional route
as well after the UK government
confirmed in the last few days it was
going to use a section 35 order for the
first time ever to stop the legislation
passing they argue that the Scottish
reforms affect uk-wide equality laws
across Scotland England and Wales
so who's right is it really about
Devolution or is it really about the
trans debate where of course people have
very uh strongly held views on both
sides we've been talking to the SNP
leader at Westminster Stephen Flem
the UK government says it's going to use
a section 35 order to block a
legislation Pastor in Scotland to make
it easier for people to legally change
their gender what's your reaction that's
it's outrageous and you know this is a
dangerous moment for Devolution and
those aren't just my words those are the
the sentiments of Mark dietford and
Wales obviously Wales is first Minister
and there's a reason for that because
the Scottish Parliament as it stands and
as we all know and puts through this
legislation on a course party basis so
members of parliament and Scottish
Parliament from the SNP labor notorious
lib Dems and the greens all voted in
favor of this legislation that passed by
two-thirds it was a Manifesto promise
from the SMP which the Scottish people
elected us upon so we're just simply
delivering upon the Mandate of the
Scottish people and now we've got Rishi
sunach and his unelected Tories in
Scotland telling us what we can and
can't do that's that's not on but isn't
a specific point that there is a concern
that the UK government have that this
impacts uk-wide legislation the equality
sense I I don't think that's reasonable
at all calculate notes obviously are
fairly esteemed member of the
conservatives did you think this was
quite do you think it's not reasonable
because you don't agree with their
position or because you don't think it
impacts uk-wide legislation so I don't
think it necessarily does impact UK why
didn't their legislation of course
Caroline Knox says I was ready to stay
there agrees with me on that point and
she was clear about that on five live
yesterday but we look at the statement
of reasons that the UK government
brought forward yesterday in a very
haphazard fashion we had stuff within
that like the the UK's I.T system won't
be able to deal with this we're talking
about a couple hundred people Max I mean
that's the extent of the argument that
the UK government are going to hear it's
utterly absorbed it's unsustainable and
it's obviously an attack on democracy
and Devolution in Scotland and if
someone goes through the you know the
easier quicker process in Scotland to
legally change their gender and then
travels to England across the border
what law applies to them then and in the
exact same way that someone living in
Ireland at this moment in time of course
could have a gender recognition
certificate is doing so at the moment
and I don't understand or appreciate
there's any concerns for people in
respect of that this is something which
the UK government are bringing so what
law would apply to that person then
would it be the UK wide law or would it
be the Scottish school I mean if they're
based in Scotland then the the situation
in Scotland would apply to them of
course they're able to travel elsewhere
in the UK but as I say there's been
examples of that for a long long time of
course we were in the European Union
there was Nations within the European
Union who had that and of course we have
yeah with Ireland we have free movement
with Ireland still notwithstanding the
fact that we're outside of the European
Union so people from Ireland who've
already got a GRC can travel into the UK
as it stands let's be clear about this
the the UK government aren't bothered
about the detail here all they're
bothered about is creating a cultural
War amongst on based on some of the most
marginalized people in society a
cultural water Times smoke out the labor
party on an issue which the labor party
appear to be struggling on and and at
the heart of this that is the key thing
and of course Scottish Devolution
Scottish democracy is just collateral
damage
um so just you would say then that the
Westminster law the rest of the UK would
apply so on on the very be on the very
front of the bill in Scotland that says
that this does not interfere with UK
equality's law Caroline Knox has been
very clear that in her view that she
doesn't believe it is the case the
Scottish Parliament Scottish
parliamentarians have been elected to
pass this legislation they have passed
this legislation on a manifestal promise
from the Scottish Scottish government to
the Scottish people on a cost party
basis this is a very basic thing
Scottish democracy under attack from the
UK toys I mean some would say that you
know it's been used as a political
football this really sensitive debate
very powerfully held opinions on both
sides a political football by both sides
from the UK government because they can
lean into the culture war and because
frankly for the SMP you guys probably
don't really mind having a row about
Devolution with Western I've seen this
argument noted we've been talking about
this in Scotland the SMP has been
talking about this in Scotland for six
years I mean what sort of forward
planning do people think we're doing
that in six years time we're going to
have an argument with the UK government
on this it's an utterly absorbed
position to take the only reason that
this is now an issue is like I say
because the UK government wants to
create that cultural war and they want
to do that so we are very marginalized
group of people that's shameful and I'm
not willing to to accept that being the
case and of course I think Scottish
democracy should be protected um I want
to talk to you a bit about strikes a
huge political issue at the minute uh
across the whole of the United Kingdom
and teachers rolling out strikes in
Scotland they want a 10 pay rise is that
affordable as it stands it probably
isn't affordable which is why there's
negotiations ongoing between the
Scottish government and the teachers
union and this is a this is an important
part of this negotiations we need to
have government ministers getting on the
table with the unions figuring out
Solutions now that's happened in
Scotland in relation to the GM being
Unite with the with the health service
we know they're getting back on the
table again uh with unison and RCN to
try and resolve the the peer disputes
there that's a good thing that's what
the UK government should be doing I
don't know why they're not getting
around the table and trying to negotiate
solutions to this well they are getting
around the table aren't they well they
appear to be broken at the table but not
listening from from what I understand to
be the case and and they are there again
seeking to divide and Rule and I don't
think that is good for public services
in England just as it wouldn't be good
for public services in Scotland but
thankfully the Scottish government are
taking a different approach um it's
about pay as well though isn't it rather
than just nice words around the
negotiation table at five percent on the
table for teachers well under inflation
and of course this is a group that have
seen you know pay restraint for a decade
yeah of course five percent I think
applies to a certain aspect especially a
group of teachers and I think for those
who are on less experience as a gradient
yes of course it's a gradient in our
garden hopefully we can find a solution
you know my wife's a teacher she's often
and I'm sure her colleagues would as
well and they've got every right to ask
for that you know it's a really
difficult time the cost of living crisis
is biting inflations that are near
40-year High the real wages are 2006
levels we know their session is going to
be the deepest and longest lasting in
the entire G7 it's right and fair that
people ask for uh Fair paid better
paying conditions and totality so she is
she telling you uh I know she's on
maternity leave but she's telling you
that look you've got to stamp up more
for teachers I was just now she's not
had that specific conversation with me
uh or on that but I'm sure if uh if she
could ensure that our colleague's got
more money then she would certainly try
like everyone is within their rights to
to ask for these things the key thing is
the government is willing to engage
willing to listen I don't see that from
the UK government I do see that from the
Scottish government I think that's
reflected in the way that the the unions
respond to both governments and we don't
see the same animosity and anger towards
the Scottish government that we do the
UK government thanks very much for being
on the program thank you
I wonder if Stephen Flynn's wife might
have a few words if she was watching
that interview uh tonight we're trying
to find out and get an update on on that
uh you are watching uh the take we're
live in Westminster for you up next we
are going to be asking a leading
anti-violence campaigner how the Met can
restore women's trust in the police
[Music]
now let's return to one of our top
stories the home office Minister Robert
generic told this program there will be
a series of changes to Police
recruitment vetting and disciplinary
processes now that's after the
conviction of the serial rapist David
Carrick who was a serving police officer
time now tonight the Prime Minister met
the Met commissioner Rowley and told him
that such abusers of power need to be
addressed immediately but behind the
political Rouse of real people and one
former officer from the north of England
has told us of her experience after she
reported her police officer ex-husband
for rape it's very powerful report comes
from our home editor Jason Farrell
a disgrace to his uniform serial rapist
David Carrick is also another alarm Bell
but police vetting has failed
the Prime Minister met with the Met
commissioner who revealed this week that
more than a thousand of his officers
remain in service despite allegations of
sexual or domestic abuse now the home
office wants all police forces to check
their own against National Police
databases I've just had a constructive
meeting with the commissioner of the
Metropolitan Police and made clear to
him and he agrees that the abuse of
power that we've seen this week is
absolutely despicable and it needs to be
addressed immediately
the problem no doubt extends Beyond
London speaking out for the first time a
retired police officer we're calling
Sally who we can't identify says she
reported her ex-husband for rape he was
also a serving officer in the north of
England who worked on sexual abuse cases
but Sally says officers handling his
case had been his colleagues or Old
Friends
he let me tell him everything that had
happened from start to finish and then
at the end of it said right let me tell
you that you know I grew up with him
and how did that make you feel
damage had been done by then then the
detective Sergeant who was leading the
investigation she told me that my
partner had worked for her as well which
shocked me
Sally learned her ex-partner was also
alleged to have been violent to his new
wife and separately a neighbor had
raised the alarm well Sally's shown us
this letter that was sent by a neighbor
complaining about the same man but this
time with a different wife and it says
the arguments are getting worse it
sounds as though it's turning physical
the worrying thing is he works for the
police and I thought he'd know better
and he ends by saying I feel for the
woman's safety
I just don't feel believed I feel like
it's all been brushed under the carpet
charges were eventually dropped against
Tally's husband and he kept his job
until retirement
during the investigation which was nine
months I'd ring up every month asking
for an update and apparently I was needy
because I was always on the phone
wanting to know what was happening
if it happened to me again I wouldn't
report it I found the investigation was
more traumatic than the actual incident
it is the story of David Carrick that
has prompted Sally to speak out do you
think that the police service is
institutionally sexist
no I don't
but the chief of police inspectors has
called for Swift action as we know it's
not the first issue in relation to
officers who have committed serious
offenses and not just in the
metropolitan police either this is a
nationwide issue
so that culture that that culture that
is pervasive in some parts of policing
needs to be rooted out
Sally says the police needs to take
complaints against its own officers more
seriously
do you think it would have been handled
differently if he wasn't a police
officer I do yeah I do and that is the
big concern that the police has a blind
spot for its own bad apples Jason
Farrell Sky News
Jason Farrell they're talking to
somebody who did make a complaint
against a serving police officer she
says that she felt that the reporting of
it and how they dealt with it was even
more traumatic than what happened to her
um well let's have a bit more in the
story now uh shall we we're joined uh by
Andrea Simon who is the director of The
Campaign group and violence against
women great to have you thank you on the
program uh today what's your
it's hard to know where to start to be
completely honest with you because it
just feels like you know we've got the
the story of David Carrick which is
frankly unbelievable yeah then you have
what happened with Sarah everard again
serving police officers people who women
should trust who are forced to trust
even if they don't trust them because
they're where they are and then you have
the Charing course text messages
what is going on in the police
um well I think these are all systemic
issues and and problems and I think for
talking about trust and and confidence
that that is something that's very
difficult to um once shattered as as in
most cases if you shatter trust it's
very hard to to rebuild that you
actually have to see an experience
change in order to to feel that trust is
is there again and I think there's a
problem with how the police respond to
crimes of domestic abuse sexual violence
um you know very few rapes that are
reported to the police end up being
charged so you've got systemic problems
with police performance in this area but
then you've got a series of scandals
that have plagued policing on top of
that and you've got issues like police
abusing their power for sexual purposes
biggest form of corruption in UK
policing and you've got um a super
complaint into police who were abusing
Partners
um as well and and that finding their
systemic deficiencies in how the police
are handling those cases
so it's it's a there's a huge amount of
work that needs to be done to restore
any sort of faith in in policing when it
comes to violence against women and
girls
um on the program today Robert generick
um outlined what the government wants to
do to toughen up vetting and also to
make it easier to effectively get rid of
people if they don't believe that
they're suitable to be officers do you
have much heart that it's going to make
a difference I mean it's taken a lot to
get to the point where they're talking
about strengthening the vetting regime
and the complaints process but obviously
these things do need to be done but they
need to be done alongside transforming
the culture of policing which is um
driving some of the the sort of fertile
conditions for misogyny and and abuse
because if if you you can try and
Institute changes you can have
corruption hotlines you can you can take
a load of different steps but if you the
culture it doesn't actually support that
work it's not going to it's not going to
result in in major change so really we
need to get to the grips with why it is
that so many cases of police misconduct
end in no further action but also why we
have things like these WhatsApp
messaging groups which are exchanging
really vile misogynistic sexist racist
messages and why that's happening within
the police force and
um and what we need to do to make sure
that we get the correct people into the
force but then we also can get people
out of the force when they don't belong
there
how do you change a culture
very it's very difficult thing to do and
it takes a very long time and I think we
have to be very honest that none of
these changes are going to make a
difference overnight we are going to be
grappling with this for a very long time
and actually there's going to be a lot
more cases that come through because of
some of the actions that have been taken
now of police abusers and we're going to
be dealing with a Fallout from that for
a very long time and there may be more
um victims of um of David Carrick you
know he was a prolific offender and um
we have to be prepared for for that and
and also I would say that the the ending
violence gets women sector who supports
those victims and survivors are there
for them and they need to be supported
and resourced in order to do that really
valuable work
I think the thing that I found
okay most depressing I guess about the
Jason Farrell report that we just
watched was when the woman said she
wished she'd never reported it and I
guess you know if you look at the
statistics that show that fewer than one
percent of uh rapes end up in a
conviction you look at stories like
David Carrick who was nicknamed uh I
mean I can't say it on air but it I
think the nickname that he had at work I
think perhaps shows that it wasn't the
most shocking thing to people who knew
him at what happened
um
why should people report
well I think you know what should happen
is if you're a victim of domestic abuse
or sexual violence you should be able to
go to the police and be treated with
respect with dignity and your your case
should be taken seriously and and the
problem is that that doesn't happen
often enough and that's whether you're
reporting a member of the public or
you're reporting a police officer and
essentially it's worse if you're
reporting a police officer and that
should be the most egregious thing
because they are there to to protect and
they are there to uphold our access to
justice so I think you know
it is very hard to say at the moment
that reporting to the police is going to
result in in a positive outcome the
whole criminal justice system to be
honest is very re-traumatizing for fixes
the courts as well it is it's the whole
process and all of it needs to be
overhauled and um you know for the
politicians they they need to be they
need to be making good and Promises
they've already apologized for the poor
treatment that rape survivors receive
and um now they're they're apologizing
obviously for for the state of policing
but we need action we don't need
apologies anymore yeah well I think we
can all agree with that uh thank you
very much for being on the program today
it's really interesting to talk to you
thank you
uh serious subjects today for us on the
take we're live in Westminster for you
up next we are going to be rounding up
everything we heard and doing our usual
at post match announcers with Sam coats
[Music]
hello welcome back live to Westminster
you're watching uh the take well now it
is time for our uh post match uh Roundup
from tonight's show we joined as usual
by Deputy Plus Credit sir uh Sam coach
we thought we'd do it a little bit
differently uh today though because Sam
I feel like you've just about recovered
Sal is that fair to say after probably
the couple of busiest weeks of your life
that's yeah that's fair enough I've seen
enough of this logo as well it's back
here to haunt you yeah
uh and what you're looking at there is
the uh all the visuals for the
Westminster accounts which we launched
about 10 days ago you and I In This Very
Room uh which in essence uh comprised of
a couple of things first of all uh
perhaps most importantly a public tool
that you at home can use it's on the
skynees app it's called the Westminster
accounts tool it allows you to look up
uh details about money and your MP and
how money flows through the financial
system and we've got some really
breaking news but I can think of a
better term news about it tonight
actually today a new version of that
tool has been launched version 1.1 uh
has gone live and what it does actually
is I add more information into it so you
can find even more detail about in often
cases what MPS are doing with the money
so that was one half of the project and
the second half of the bit that I did
primarily was a whole load of stories
tales that we came across after digging
into the numbers now we learned some
things as a result of that journalism we
find out who the ultimate source of some
of the donations were uh for instance
npm connect was actually a a Tory labor
donor called Peter herd and some
Mysteries remain who is behind the IX
Wireless donations to 24 Tory MPS but
the most interesting thing for me has
been how this whole exercise has been
picked up by quite so many people
looking through Regional newspapers over
the weekend there was a lot in there
they too have started to pull together
the threads about how money Works in our
system that's perhaps the most rewarding
part of the project so far I don't think
it probably gives away any secrets to
say that your phone you said that we
launched it here and as soon as you got
up your phone and your WhatsApp
basically exploded with MPS getting in
touch with you how has the response been
in Westminster look
there have been MPS who have publicly
welcomed it there have been MPS who
shall we say did the opposite uh uh
pretty much in private uh people didn't
like it uh in some cases for for a
variety of reasons some which I you know
I thought were interesting some of which
were completely uh invalid in my view
and some of it was expressed with with
some degree of uh passion uh often a
nice website often in my direction
somebody said they were going to cancel
this guy's subscription uh uh others
talked about uh groups of MPS shunning
us uh so I think there has been some
there has been a bit of a bit of there
have been a bit of passion but that but
but but that that this thing is coming
out of it and um actually I think
broadly this really is an exercise that
we hope is for good good news and thanks
very much for being on the show always
good to have your analysis that is it
for the take we'll be back next week of
course and every Wednesday at 9 00 PM
next up it is Sky News at 10 see you on
Sunday for superbridge on Sunday thanks
for watching
[Music]